going on here you've got doctors here
people who have taken an oath people who
are supposed to be protecting people and
they're turning people away does this go
against everything that they sample well
I think there are two key issues there
and it's more to do with administrative
issues rather than a question of ethos
as it were so the first is that
receptionists are often under the
impression that they need paperwork or
ID from patients before they register
them and that's completely
understandable there are many good
practical reasons for having patience
addresses and for checking their IDs
when you register them for example if
you are seeing a hospital consultant in
the hospital consultant will use the
address registered at your GP to
correspond with you there are also
reasons to do with patient
confidentiality because patients
understandably would not want their
records to be sent to the wrong address
if perfectly good practical reasons for
receptionist's trying to get paperwork
and ID from patients I think there has
been a lack of clarity about the rules
and it's good that NHS England have made
it absolutely clear that paperwork is
not required it's not just useful for
asylum see because it's also useful for
homeless people but this is really an
administrative issue it's an issue of
receptionist's often not knowing what
the rules are and of really trying their
best to get as much information as
possible to ensure that records are safe
and the hospitals and indeed all
healthcare professionals can communicate
with patients effectively it's very
important to remember that GP practices
are the organisational hub of all
patient data and records so wherever you
are seen regardless of whether it to a
walk-in centre or hospital or wherever
the records from that encounter go back
to the general practice so important to
have good robust methods of ensuring
that correct data is saved on systems
good but we're just merely speaking to
the receptionist to solve the problem
because a lot of people who go to see a
doctor may not want to give those
details they may not have that
information they may come from a country
where they're just so used to not
wanting to give out such information
about themselves there's a lot of
cultural differences that can affect
this as well absolutely we know well
that there are things like language
barriers a lot of asylum seekers have
come through war zones of massive
psychological issues and it's very
important that we do our best to reduce
those barriers and enable them to access
health care it's important both from an
altruistic point of view to ensure that
they get the best health care possible
but it's also important with respect to
the rest of the public there are
diseases like HIV and TB which are
contagious which can spread to the wider
population as it were as well so very
good reasons for clarifying this and I
think the Department of Health has done
the right thing by making absolutely
clear that asylum seekers do not need ID
and paperwork to register with GPS and
there are collateral benefits of this
for other people who are not asylum
seekers who may not have records like
homeless people as well do you know of
doctors within your professional
community colleagues friends who have
turned people I so I think it's very
important to be clear about this
doctor's GPS actually have no
participation in registering patient so
when I work as a GP for example I don't
personally register do you register
patients at all my administrative staff
do that because the receptionist is the
buffer they absolutely right precisely
and in fact the vast majority of GPS ooh
I know and indeed the Care Quality
Commission CQC has highlighted this
actually go the extra mile often to make
sure that they give the best possible
care to these people who have come from
very difficult circumstances who have
language barriers and so on often
getting interpreters involved often
spending far more than the 10 minutes
were allocated per consultation so I
think GPS themselves and indeed all
healthcare professionals and even
receptionist are trying their best it is
really an issue of a lack of clarity so
far about the rules and hopefully this
new clarity and the new statement from
NHS England will help overcome that just
really there will be some people who say
that a GP surgeries are already full you
know you only have to phone your doctor
eight o'clock in the morning and hope
that you might get an appointment at 5am
a week on Tuesday and being live here
but it is hard to get an appointment as
it is so some people will be saying
doctors are already oversubscribed it
should be happy perhaps other services
for asylum seekers well I think the key
way to solve that problem really is to
give general practitioners and primary
care the resources that they need to see
their patients effectively and this
isn't just for asylum seekers
for the wider population as a whole at
the moment we've got a situation where
there is rising demand huge financial
pressures on practices a massive exodus
of GPS and lots of practices are closing
down simply because they don't have the
funds to pay their staff and to see
patients safely so that is really the
most important issue in this I think if
we can resolve that then receptionists
will have time to clarify rules for
example and GPS will have time to give
these patients who have come from very
difficult circumstances the care that
they need okay dr. Khan thanks so much
for you I thanks going in this afternoon